laurent alors on va ça c'est donc le
xvème siècle on va revenir un petit peu
en avant c'est à dire un siècle et demi
c'est à dire qu'au milieu du 14e siècle
avec umberto eco alors je dis tout de
suite donc si vous aimez les romans
policiers à la conan doyle agatha
christie
ce livre est pour vous puis si vous
aimez aussi les récits un peu subtile de
borgès se livrer pour vous aussi si vous
aimez les querelles les querelles
théologiques
ce livre est pour vous aussi et puis si
vous aimez les romans historiques se
livrer pour vous aussi d'envoyer ses
tarifs des hôtels c'est une bibliothèque
c'est un livre qui peut satisfaire
beaucoup de gens alberto échos oui il
sait donc que 14ème siècle c'est que
c'est dans l'italie d'une heure c'est
une italie très différente de celle là
c'est une italie très différente parce
que mon histoire se passe dans une
abbaye bénédictine habité par deux mois
qui vient de toute l'europe
il ya seulement petit alien et qui vit
un corps d'un dans un milieu qui n'est
pas le milieu de ville marchande qui
sont déjà en train de fleurir en italie
donc c'est encore un moyen âge un peu
arriérés et je le dis un certain point
le manuscrit que mon auteur a soudain
melk et cris dans le 14ème siècle mais
évidemment sa mentalité est la mentalité
du 3e 12e et peut-être un cordon jura
présentent plutôt un dernier moyen-âge
qui a déjà la conscience qu'il ya
quelque chose d'étrange qui se passe un
dea pour commencer les gens commencent à
parler rebeu guerre et à ce jour là elle
livre commence cinq ans après six ans
après la mort d d'un thé alighieri donc
lorsqu'il ya déjà et littérature
vulgaire tandis que le - demont abbaye
continue à parler entre en latin donc
c'est un il ya plus d'un siècle
entre histoire cette histoire là et il y
a il ya vraiment le moyen-âge qui n'est
pas encore arrivé à à la renaissance
sauf à travers certains livres et
certains personnages parce qu'enfin les
livres qu'elle veut humaniste de couvre
était là voilà était là la découverte ce
manuscrit est tout à fait laventure de
ces pionniers qui sont allés et piller
les monastères pour amener les lebron
alors le donc une abbaye bénédictine
et puis deux personnages qui s'en
approche au début alors on peut dire
tout de suite que c'est sherlock holmes
et conan doyle simplement il s'appelle
pas comme ça ils s'appellent l'unss et
guillaume de baskerville et l'autre qui
est un excellent visiteurs et puis c'est
il ya son secrétaire qui est un novice
bénédictins qui s'appelle adso de melk
alors ils sont les entrent dans l'abbaye
et là il s'est passé quelque chose
d'extraordinaire oui on peut des crimes
fois qu'il ya un mystère
il y as mystère il ya des témoins qui
marins par jour suivant parait-il a un
plan et suivant les déverser des
citations de l'apocalypse et oui puisque
mon personnage avait été un inquisiteur
c'est un inquisiteur en crise qui en
certains points abandonner ce métier
parce qu'il n'avait plus les idées
claires il ne comprenait plus d où était
la vertu la sainte et et où étaient les
crimes ce qui nous arrive souvent et
dont il est chargé de deux de découvrir
le mystère ma mettons qu'il est chargé
d'une autre entreprise il est là comme
un baladeur de l'empereur pour nous
rencontre très compliquée et il est là
en tant que lui un temps condisciples ou
amis des guillaume des eaux calmes qui
est un grand philosophe
l'époque et qui avait l'air d'être très
intéressé à la vie des mots et la vie
des signes pour dire l'histoire d'une
façon un peu cavalière et donc ce
personnage à 3 peut-être plus que trois
problème la mission politique
ce petit jeu auquel il a décidé de
s'adonner de découvrir les coupables et
sa curiosité sa cure son amour pour la
conjoncture il faut dire qu'il abhorre
une intelligence exceptionnelle
et là il a une culture exceptionnelle
intelligence exceptionnelle il faut dire
que le dialogue entre lui et son lait
sont secrétaires sont évidemment tout à
fait savoureux pas exceptionnel parce
que je lui fait dire c'est que des gens
à cette époque là on dit chez lui mais
dans sa bouche des bessanais d'afrique
on lui confie la mission de trouver la
vérité parce qu'on sait quand même qu'il
a il a une intuition il a une
intelligence et une curiosité il a
d'ailleurs il est éblouissant veux pas
raconter ça mais quand tu n'entres déjà
il résout un problème ni extraordinaire
oui mais ça c'est la faute à voltaire de
la patience et la ligue
alors si vous voulez m'obliger à dire
que guillaume est très sympathique mais
vous savez ce mon fils et je voudrais
bien son enfant bon alors il va se
passer d alors là on trouve tout les
ingrédients du mystère parce que il ya
et il y a une et des formules blizzard
dont il faut découvrir le sens il y à
une bibliothèque eux dans laquelle
personne n'a le droit d'entrée il ya des
passages secrets il ya des miroirs qui
sont en vérité des portes etc
et puis il ya des cadavres il y en a
qu'on retrouve noyé dans une baignoire
lors qu'on trouve la tête dans le seau
le moule vous reposer le sens du cochon
qu'on n'ait tué enfin bon des choses
absolument abominable mais lors des
petites choses que je trouve très très
drôle moi par exemple là vous êtes
l'inventeur
je crois vraiment vous êtes l'inventeur
d'une forme de suicide qui n'a jamais
existé
le suicide par absorption d'un manuscrit
d'aristote ça c'est formidable ça je
dire le suicide par aristote c'est une
découverte génial oui mais il ya déjà
dans l'apocalypse leader
livre à manger oui mais aristote ah oui
aristote l'aspect nouveau qu'est ce que
vous allez faire plaisir à beaucoup
d'étudiants suscité par aristote c'est
une chose qui était assez joli alors on
s'aperçoit finalement que tout le drame
tout le mystère vient donc de cette
salle en fin de cet empire plutôt qui
est la bibliothèque au centre du
monastère oui les problèmes s'ils
bibliothèque fait pour conserver pour
distribuer ou pour tâcher le livre c'est
un problème qui existe aujourd'hui
on a beaucoup des bibliothèques qui
cache la bibliothèque qui distribue et
de bibliothèques qui qui qui garde
mais ce moment là et pour guillaume
c'est un problème culturel politique
métaphysique à la fois cette
bibliothèque qui est en même temps par
labyrinthe est une allégorie du monde
une allégorie de la recherche une
allégorie de la vérité et est bon mais
je ne peux pas expliquer tous les secret
mystérieux parce que si vous dites ok
donc on a tué de moins sûr il ya la
vérité c'est que mx inquisiteurs qui
deviennent un enquêteur et qui est comme
une sorte d'ancêtre de l'auguste du pain
qui va inventer 1835 edgar allan poe et
qui il voit il sait que le premier mort
a été assassiné après assassiné qui
n'était pas un accident c'est l'autre
qui meurent ensuite a commis empêché de
sodomie avec le premier mort et ça ne
m'intéresse pas alors que tous les
couvents tout l'abbaye pense que c'est
une histoire de moeurs qui se cache là
il sait innocent aucune importance ici
il y a une autre jolie pour que l'autre
ait commis le péché de sodomie c'est que
celui-ci qui avait un petit peu c'est
entrer dans la bibliothèque lui ai
promis quelque chose c'est quelque chose
doit être
et problème c'est la luxure de
l'intelligence alors qu'il découvre qu
au dessous de la luxure sexuelle signé
et de la luxure de l'intelligence et du
savoir du savoir si c'est le mot qui est
employé et du savoir et de d'une
conception affreuse de la vérité parce
qu'il y a des gens ya là des gens qui
meurent et qui tue pour pour affirmer
pour imposer leurs vérités qui a brûlé
aux mains un temps sa commune luxure
terrible aussi air justement prouve
cette luxure du savoir luxure de la
chaire qui passe aussi dans ce livre on
vous la connaissez vous la luxure dû
selon vous la connaissez je disais tout
à l'heure vous étiez le roland barthes
italien vous la pratiquez cette
structure les sépultures du savoir on
écrase toujours un roman sur soi même
qu'ils soient à la recherche ou san
antonio on écrit quelque chose sur ses
propres vices alors les îles donc oui
évidemment l intellectuel que vous avez
le risque de parler d'eux mêmes de la
dhuys du soir du vice de la connaissance
réelle et le vis de la culture vous
parce que je lis tout de suite si tu es
dans une histoire policière il ya aussi
des pages admirables mais alors sur les
rebords history sur notre seigneur
jésus-christ sur l'antéchrist sur
l'architecturé etc etc
ça c'est le bis médiévale alors le moyen
âge comme vie c'est comme passion la
structure même des chapitres
qui chapitre par chapitre et puise
l'univers de la connaissance est très
étroit médiévale et dans ce sens là je
me suis mis dans la situation d'un mois
j'ai essayé décrit comme ils auraient
été créés et les citations latines
alors les citations latines dont vous ne
donnez jamais à traduction non traduites
et je dois y a tout de suite je ne
connais pas le latin mais simplement ont
peu à peu près tous les sens et toute
façon on peut les sauter ça n'a pas
d'importance
oui j'ai essayé d'expliquer à quelqu'un
qui m'a dit pourquoi tu n'as pas traduit
on se pose maintenant le problème pour
l'édition américaine parce qu'au médium
et les italiens le latin le comprend le
français
mais les américains ça c'est du grec
pour pour le latin et aime ma réponse et
lorsque nous entendons une symphonie de
mahler nous nous comprenons très bien
qu'il fait des citations mais c'est ne
pas nécessaire de comprendre exactement
lesquels et c'est nécessaire d day de
comprendre qu'il ya certains jeux un
signe de l'hésitation musique de la
citation est nécessaire et et j'ai une
autre réaction intéressant dans jeune
homme de 18 ans auquel je demandé il me
disait qu'il avait aimé le livre et je
le dis mais là on parle d'aidé
d'histoire ont pas de philosophie on
parle il ya des citations latines et et
toi alors aller m'en fous il a dit parce
que ce sont deux façons de transformer
le labyrinthe des tridimensionnel dans
un labyrinthe tetra dimensionnelle
où il y à même la dimension
intellectuelle de l'inde et de la
complexité et et on découvre toujours à
travers ses lecteurs des aspects du
livre qu'on ignorait un vent j'ai
beaucoup apprécié cette réaction d'anne
et vous êtes un jeune homme digne hareng
mais vous êtes très pervers parce que en
vérité cette bibliothèque qui est le
comble de la logique nous amène à la
confusion
cette cette abbaye qui paraît si oscille
elle aussi logique si sage on s'aperçoit
que la nuit ça n'est que turpitudes et
mensonge etc
vous êtes terrible est alors en plus de
ça les jolies dr vous permettait parce
que le
de batterie basse car oui évidemment ça
rappelle le shin beth services et conan
doyle
et puis le l'octogénaire aveugle qui est
vérité le vrai maître de la bibliothèque
il a un nom qui ressemble à celui de
borgès etc vous amuser comme un fou et
je suis persuadé citation exacte des
citations fausses
à propos de ce lieu par vers vous
connaissez des autres lieux en dehors de
cette abbaye qui soit un peu moins
pervers
ici par exemple servir de frontière
ce sont les délégations qui se pensent
que sait-on jamais nous sommes entourés
par des millions de voyageurs
non mais c'est très important ce sont
les petits traités qu'il ya à
l'intérieur du point de vue théologique
par exemple je me souviens d'un chapitre
sur la métaphore si la métaphore est
quelque chose de bien du point de vue
spirituel ou non et c'est qui est
extraordinaire pour toi les rues de
bourg l'aveuglent que les patrons de la
bibliothèque ne veux que personne est
taxée à ses livres interdits dont il a
fait empoisonner tout le feu y avait là
faut pas dire ça aux malheureux faut pas
dire ça
ap d'ailleurs catherine de médicis non
plus ce n'est pas avec des buy dumas
dans l'année de diane hall est aussi une
histoire de livres pour ados et ça
existe on le fait on le fait jus du mal
à trouver un poison qui pouvait marcher
et j'avais écrit même de l'être un ami
de l'universitaire lui disant je
voudrais un poison comme ça comme ça il
m'a répondu le poison que tu cherches
que c'est un certain point je me suis
aperçu que ces lettres dans mon tiroir
était très très compromettants et je
laissais détruite parce qu à après avoir
écrit le roman tout le monde aura pu
s'apercevoir de mon innocence mais avant
je vis un moment de deux heures comme ça
vous êtes terrible alors et j'espère
juste cette citation parce que c'est
pour montrer votre humour
alors une conversation entre entre
guillaume et puis son secrétaire ils
cherchent évidemment les solutions au
mystère du monastère mais à l'heure aux
hedge commenté vous êtes encore loin de
la solution
j'en suis très près de guillaume mais je
ne sais pas de laquelle donc vous n'avez
pas qu'une seule réponse à vos questions
adso si tel était le cas j'enseignerai
la théologie à paris à paris ils ont
toujours la vraie réponse jamais dit me
dit guillaume
mais ils sont très sûrs de leurs erreurs
voilà